monsieur le monsieur le président
je pense que vous vous m'entendez mes
chers collègues nous ont tendance cet
après-midi le président du conseil
régional de la Guadeloupe monsieur
Richelieu dans le cadre de la
préparation de notre rapport sur
l'évolution institutionnelle des
Outre-mer nous vous remercions vivement
monsieur le Président pour votre
participation nous achevons avec vous
notre cycle d'audition qui nous a permis
de consulter les exécutifs
ultramarins
comme pour ces derniers une trame de
questions que vous a été adressée pour
recueillir votre bilan de l'organisation
institutionnelle et des règles de
fonctionnement de la Région Guadeloupe
nous savons que des réflexions
approfondies sont en cours sur votre
territoire pour avancer des propositions
d'adaptation de votre statut où on est
de vous à ce stade que pouvez-vous dire
sur ces débats est-ce que vous en
attendez quel est votre vision sur le
champ des possibles ouverts par rapport
perspective de la perspective de
révision constitutionnelle de 2023 je
vais donc vous donner la parole monsieur
le Président sur ces points dans le
cadre de votre exposés éliminaires et
nous vous interrogerons ensuite avec
Micheline Jacques si vous en êtes
d'accord qui est co-rapporteur ainsi que
mes collègues qui participent à cette
audition sur la base de la trame qui a
été adressée qui se veut avant tout un
guidage au sein de cette discussion mais
je vous laisse tout de suite la parole
la parole monsieur le président
bonjour Merci vous m'entendez bien
parfaitement parfaitement
piratage en Guadeloupe donc nous avions
dû effectivement
on va dire cela faire un mécanisme pour
pouvoir être en direct avec
éventuellement la bricole un peu pour
être
parce que
c'est zoom et là vous avez envoyé un
un lien qui est un peu difficilement là
peut quand même bricoler quelque chose
pour pouvoir répondre à cette audition
donc bonjour à toutes et à tous merci
donc je voulais déjà rappeler le
contexte dans lequel nous nous sommes
aujourd'hui et vous connaissez un peu la
situation des régions
d'outre-mer nous nous sommes un peu
comme la réunion nous sommes
départements et régions
il est d'abord important de relever le
contexte de notre local se déroule cette
audition le contexte de guerre en
Ukraine dans les effets se font
ressentir jusqu'en Guadeloupe
au travers de la Horse du coup de
carburant du prix de la matière première
et de la pénurie de certains produits de
polyan nécessité
l'augmentation du prix de l'essence à la
décision sport sur notre population
aussi
essentielles de notre collectivité
régionale sont aujourd'hui querelli le
triplement du coût du fret maritime et
aérien a exposé notre exportations
agricole il y a eu des incidences sur
l'activité de certains producteurs par
exemple le melon
un contexte de forte tension sociale lié
à la crise de novembre 2021 et à la
question de la réintégration des
soignants et portée par un collectif de
syndicats aujourd'hui au cœur de notre
actualité et le débat parlementaire
enfin au texte national la tempête qui
vous a fait très mal ces derniers jours
nous subissons dans nos îles les
premiers effets du changement climatique
invasion
des coraux augmentation et violence des
phénomènes cycloniques
déjà que la Guadeloupe était un poids de
l'ensemble des risques majeurs naturels
des risques sismiques volcaniques
cyclonique le réchauffement climatique
fait apparaître de nouveaux risques
parce que nous sommes un archipel ville
au milieu de l'océan
le phénomène n'est pas sans conséquence
nous le fonctionnement de nos grandes
particules bon aéroport
du monde nous devons investir dans les
prochaines années pour éviter d'être
coupé du monde en cas de catastrophe
naturelle et œuvrer pour développer
notre autonomie notamment alimentaire
les pays du G20 vont reverser au pays
vulnérables 100 milliards de dollars sur
le montant global de 64 milliards de
dollars des droits de tirage spéciaux
BTS émis par les fonds monétaires
internationales
jusque-là le G20 n'avait jamais trouvé
d'accord sur un montant à reversé au
pays en développement
jusqu'ici les promesses
à environ 45 milliards de dollars
DTS sont en avoir le réserve
international
FMI pour compléter les réserves de
change officielle de ces pays membres
ils sont répartis en fonction de leur
quote-part de chaque pays au FMI
en conséquence en temps normal les plus
gros le plus gros va au pays les plus
riches
la Guadeloupe qui n'est pas
la pauvre mais le territoire vulnérable
peut-elle prétendre à bénéficier de
cette fois
de qualité d'origine
nous impose
de réinterroger notre relation avec le
pouvoir central et l'Europe
de la souveraineté alimentaire sans
redimensionnés le programme d'option
spécifique à l'éloignement et à
l'insularité
merci avec l'aide de l'État et afin que
plus grand nombre d'agriculture
bénéficient de ces aides juste là
quelques mots avant de pouvoir vous
entendre et vous répondre vraiment dans
le concret de cette audition
merci monsieur le Président enfin sachez
que c'est ces mots préliminaires fixent
le décor comme nous l'avions imaginé et
donc on va rentrer dans le vif du sujet
en deux temps si vous le voulez bien je
vais traiter la partie bilan de
l'organisation institutionnelle de la
Guadeloupe et puis j'essayerai la parole
ma collègue Miss injack sur la partie
révision constitutionnelle telle que le
présent Macron là envisageait un moment
donné et des réflexions que vous avez en
cours sur votre territoire alors sur la
partie organisation de l'organisation
bilan de l'organisation
j'ai presque envie de vous dire quel
bilan faites-vous de l'organisation
institutionnelle actuelle du point de
vue de l'exercice démocratique de
l'efficacité de la conduite des
politiques publiques et de l'adaptation
de ces politiques aux réalités et
besoins du territoire
quels sont les principales puisque vous
en êtes indéfini à terre motivation de
l'appel de Fort-de-France dont la
continuité des auditions de la Réunion
et de la Martinique et je ne doute pas
que vous avez également dire sur le
sujet et puis pour aborder la trame de
questions qui a été également adressée
évoquer l'aspect compétence adaptation
des normes
sur des exemples d'actions ou de projets
qui ont été contrarié entravés bloqué
par l'organisation institutionnelle ou
normative actuelle et souhaitez-vous par
exemple les réflexions actuelles vous
amènent à imaginer des compétences dans
des nouveaux domaines est-ce que vous
envisageriez par exemple un aller-retour
des restitutions à l'inverse de champ de
compétences vers l'état qui peut aussi
être envisagé bien évidemment est-ce
qu'il y a une aspiration du territoire
de la Guadeloupe à obtenir un pouvoir
normatif dans certains domaines voilà ce
sont des sujets sur lesquels on a très
hâte d'entendre votre position monsieur
le président
et bien merci effectivement nous avons
reçu les questions nous avons travaillé
j'ai travaillé avec mes collaborateurs
enfin sur leur contexte sur la situation
pourquoi non effectivement nous avons
été consignateurs de la période de
France c'est vrai il faut leur dire
aujourd'hui qu'il y a un écheveur
vraiment des compétences et surtout
administratif qui accentue manque de
cohérence des actions et de l'efficacité
des politiques publiques
communs
département région et nous en avions
dernièrement je crois il y a deux ans
avant le covid de discuter au Congrès
pour savoir un peu quel chemin prendre
n'échappe pas ici en Guadeloupe à la
fois abstention à chaque élection vous
le voyez l'augmentation du vote en
faveur des parties extrémistes nous
faisons aussi face il faut le dire à une
profonde rupture entre notre population
et la classe politique tout cela rend
toute action et initiative de manière
inaudible il faut le dire cette crise de
confiance installe durablement et ne
fait que ça quoi
l'organisation actuelle
l'ami de souplesse ni l'agilité qui sont
indispensable pour agir efficacement
nécessaire de poser la question de
compétences de l'État qui pourrait être
décentralisée et donc l'instruction
pourrait être transférée à certains
collectivités en fonction des
collectivités
archéologiques la loi sur l'eau je pense
que ce sont des compétences que la
Région Guadeloupe aurait elle-même plus
peut-être menée nous avons les
techniciens qui travaillent qui était à
la DL qui était un autre service
et il y a pas que cela il y a la
déviation
des études à gauche et à droite ils
prennent du temps à chaque fois il y a
encore des demandes donc voilà tout ça
nous retard donc aujourd'hui c'est cela
il y a quelques années
le terme de coproduction
de Guadeloupe des autres régions qu'on
savait un appel solennel à l'état pour
qu'il redéfini ces modernise c'est
rapport avec le collectivité en fonction
de leur spécificité il est clair que
nous parlons de région par exemple un
peu des régions européennes qui sont de
très grande région et par rapport aux
jeunes de France qui sont cinq fois plus
faibles la Guadeloupe et la Martinique
la Réunion et autres nous sommes des
petites régions à 8000 km de de
l'Hexagone donc nous avons plus de
difficultés donc dans notre document
nous souhaitons un nouveau cadre
d'application des politiques publiques
pour qu'elles soient plus proche des
réalités de chaque région il faudrait
aujourd'hui placer le levier de décision
plus près des territoires et souligner
surtout la nécessité
une nouvelle politique économique
et écologique
nous savons que cet appel intervient
dans un contexte de fin de l'état
providence
mais la question liées à la
modernisation des rapports entre les
collectivités et à l'appartenance à la
République doivent être abordés et on va
passer donc
aujourd'hui des exemples
concernant compétences
et surtout les normes qui existent oui
on en a la région postula programme
valorisation et de préservation de ces
littoraux au titre de l'économie bleue
qui s'insulte le plan océan un programme
que nous avons inscrit depuis 2015 et
plus de 30 millions nous souffrons de
l'existence de contraintes liés à la loi
sur l'eau je vous le disais avec la DAL
avec le Conservatoire du littoral la
gestion des procédures environnementales
pour notre région et financée par la
Région accuse de retard considérable
alors aujourd'hui cette situation a des
incidences pour la commande publique
dans le BTP
la gestion du covid ne nous a pas
arrangé nous regrettons aussi
le consultation et je l'ai à plusieurs
reprises signifiait on préfère au
gouvernement avec l'ARS il prenait les
décisions sur consultées les présidents
de département de région les élus les
parlementaires et je pense que
j'aime le dire le meilleur expert des
affaires
nous devons désormais nous interroger
sur une nécessité de refonte de nos
rapports avec les autorités en charge de
la santé
absolue d'agir avec pragmatique et
efficacité dès lors que la santé
est indispensable pour avancer
vous avez parlé de compétences dans le
nouveau domaine
je dirais sur la biodiversité
l'environnement aux énergies
renouvelables
il y a des lois qui existent des
compétences confiées aux régions
notamment dans l'Hexagone n'ont pas les
mêmes nous n'avons pas les mêmes
spécificités que ces grandes régions de
3 millions d'habitants de 5 millions de
plus
comme
de la déconcentration de cette fois
j'ai demandé à ce que a plusieurs
reprises à l'état que le préfet de
Guadeloupe puisse bénéficier de
dérogation pour accélérer et mettre en
œuvre certaines politiques publiques
jusqu'à maintenant ça n'a pas été fait
nous avons subiionnage je pense qu'avec
cette dérogation nous aurions pu aller
encore plus loin avec cette même
dérogation nous aurions pu effectivement
aller plus vite dans les travaux entamés
par le département par la région pour
pouvoir soulager les guadeloupéens qui
reste sans eau pendant des semaines
donc je le dis aujourd'hui c'est
plus précisément plusieurs même
réalisation
nous avons la méditation en énergie nous
avons démontré un peu notre capacité à
avancer de 18 à 20% du mix énergétique
nous sommes passés à plus de 40%
aujourd'hui
nous devons inclure aussi cette question
fiscale
plus sur le continent les femmes de
l'électrification de la mobilité va
rendre indispensable la refonte du
modèle de taxation qui s'appuie sur la
consommation de carburant de
l'aménagement par exemple du territoire
nous subissons aussi trop souvent une
vision étroite et dogmatique qui
prennent les projets de développement
faut le rappeler
notre développement
et envisageable que sur 23 % de ce
surface il est urgent de revisiter les
procédures au niveau de
décentraliser donc pensons notamment
certaines missions
dans le section pourrait être confié à
la collectivité chef de fil du
Développement et de l'Aménagement du
Territoire cela peut même s'envisager à
doit constant sans évolution
législatives majeures et je pense que
nous gagnons beaucoup en cohérence et de
là je pense que ce soit un départ pour
que nous puissions redonner confiance à
notre population
merci monsieur le Président on va
aborder si vous le voulez maintenant
l'organisation des institutions que vous
vivez pleinement évidemment pour en être
au coeur est-ce que l'organisation
actuelle et les règles de fonctionnement
de la région sont satisfaisants de votre
point de vue quel bidon provisoire
faites-vous du contrat de convergence
concerté qui a été mis en place il y a
maintenant un an donc en 2021 est-ce
qu'une collectivité unique qui se
substituerait à la région au département
vous paraîtrait pertinente pour
améliorer l'efficacité des politiques
publiques et puis quelles leçons surtout
vous tirez de votre voisine d'expérience
martiniquaise de cette collectivité
unique est-ce que c'est un modèle qui
peut inspirer voilà voilà les quelques
réflexions que je voudrais qu'on aborde
avant d'aborder le rôle de l'État
j'aime le dire tous ceux qui est fait
pour nous et sans nous a fait contre
nous
nous avons
vécu que l'État l'effet néfastes 2016
institutionnelles de l'environnement et
de l'enchaînement des compétences nous
devons également reconnaître
l'efficacité des politiques publiques ne
repose pas uniquement sur le changement
institutionnel et sanitaire
même ceux qui ont connu une évolution
institutionnelle
le droit pour être efficace doit être au
service du citoyen et seulement au
service du citoyen par l'institution
et le sens même de la simplification de
la modernisation de l'action publique
locale que nous mettons en pratique
Guadeloupe nous avons la présidence la
CPAP et je crois l'une des conférences
on me dit la seule conférence qui se
réunit aussi souvent que nécessaire pour
discuter décider de grandes politiques
publiques territoriale
dans le convergence
et mutualiser les moyens
entre la Région le Département c'est
vrai nous avons installé des commissions
mixtes qui travaillent ensemble pour la
culture pour l'agriculture et la pêche
nous sommes au début de cette de ce
contrat de gouvernance département
a été installé il y a juste un nom
la réforme du congrès des élus
départementaux peut être une proposition
additionnelle afin qu'il se transforme
le Parlement local
informalisant la présence des mers je
pense qu'on a beaucoup de possibilités
beaucoup d'atouts pour pouvoir avancer
ensemble et pouvoir prendre des
responsabilités pour mener à bien les
politiques publiques
merci monsieur le Président et
concernant le rôle de l'État puisque
c'est un rôle central évidemment sur nos
territoires comment est-ce que vous
jugez le rôle d'accompagnement de
celui-ci pour exercer vos compétences
les transferts se déroulent-ils dans de
bonnes conditions est-ce que la
déconcentration c'est à dire les moyens
de l'État sur le territoire vous semble
adapter à vos réalités locales faut-il
redéfinir par exemple comme ça a été
suggéré par Monsieur les chimie le rôle
du préfet en Guadeloupe et dans les
outre-mer de manière plus générale
aujourd'hui il y a une tradition de
subsister les vérités réflexes dans le
commerce
on voit quelquefois prendre une volonté
de mettre en place une recentralisation
librement
et ce principe doit être respecté nous
l'avons vécu
j'allais vécu lors de la mise en place
des communautés d'agglomération on a
forcé la commune à entrer dans une
circonscription
malgré les deux ponts qui séparent à la
Grande Terre et la Guadeloupe
et pourtant la loi le dit les
collectivités librement
l'État n'est pas assez un conseil ou en
accompagnant
positionner davantage un contrôle de
l'égalité plutôt qu'un contrôle
l'opportunité
la gestion des Francs européens par
exemple
notamment le feignant la pêche et
l'agriculture l'état accentue le
contrôle et alourdir la solution des
dossiers
la collectivité doit a dû assumer seul
les conséquences de la crise sanitaire
47 millions perdu
l'absence de ressources on pense à toi
pour nous
les relations je les disques il y a un
moment avec le RS et nous qui avons dû
acheter des masques
aux pompiers aux infirmiers
au médecin taximan
à ce moment-là on n'a pas vu le travail
de l'État on s'est battu
aujourd'hui
la politique publique stratégique se
développe sur un temps long
il dépasse largement le temps de passage
de fonctionnaires de l'État dans le
territoire
l'eau et le locaux de terrain pouvant
certaines fois le retrouver face à un
manque d'échange et le dialogue avec les
services déconcentrés et ne tiennent pas
compte de l'urgence de notre territoire
et on l'a vu à plusieurs reprises
x 3 étages de compétences des services
de concentrés qui pourraient être
exercés par les collectivités
territoriales notamment en Guadeloupe
modifier le décret définissant le
fonctionnement de la CTP pour que les
politiques menées par l'État
dans son domaine de compétence soit
débattu évaluer avec les élus locaux
nous avons même pensé
associer vraiment aussi les mères
de même il serait souhaitable
de chaque année le directeur général de
la RS présidente
d'exécution du programme régional de
santé comme ça se fait je crois avec la
sonnerie de compte
on s'était
suivie de débat
la procédure de la RS par le biais de
cette compétence la déprogrammer le
texte scan par exemple sans concertation
avec les élus locaux
nous avons mis en place plein de
financement pour deuxième pièce canne et
bien l'ancienne directeur l'ancienne
directrice de la RS la déprogrammée sans
que nous soyons informés et vous avez le
sénateur Théophile qui a vos côtés qui
s'est déplacé même en Amérique pour
aller voir un peu le modèle stable le
plus adapté pour nous en Guadeloupe
il faut vraiment juridiquement
et après service de consciente à agir en
toute autonomie
la nécessité d'échanger avec les élus et
les acteurs locaux et sans retour
d'expérience nous la voyons par exemple
actuellement sur les difficultés que
nous avons dès qu'il peut en Guadeloupe
ou des familles sont submergées par des
ravines de l'eau qui rentre dans les
dans les maisons et quand vous curé pour
protéger votre population céramine vous
êtes attaqué et vous êtes
là vous êtes attendu par la police de
l'eau et moi-même personnellement à
l'époque j'étais condamné parce que j'ai
dû dégager des familles mais surtout
nettoyer un canal très important qui lit
la ville de Bao et leur grand centre
commercial qui se trouve sur notre
territoire donc c'est admissible
peut-être que si nous avions eu des
morts et j'avais laissé le canal en
l'état j'aurais pas été condamné alors
concernant le préfet
nous sommes je suis sûr du principe
constitutionnel
se gère et s'administrer pour ma part
c'est cette base
j'entretiens personnellement le club en
relation avec le préfet
qui est bien avec qui j'entretiens
collaboration étroite sur les dossiers
les terrains communs par contre comme je
le dis il faudrait effectivement que
l'État reste dans ses missions que les
régions les collectivités ont plus de
responsabilités plus de compétences
contrôler quand même par le contrôle de
l'égalité
merci monsieur le Président on va passer
maintenant à la partie constitutionnelle
de cette audition étant précisé que la
mission outremer risque d'être annoncé
dans l'hémicycle un peu plus tôt que
nous ne l'avions pensé donc on s'en
excuse par avance monsieur le Président
la mission outre-mer les crédits de la
mission outre-mer pour 2023 risque
d'être annoncé un petit peu en avance et
Michel Jack étant par ailleurs
rapporteur de cette mission on va devoir
condenser un petit peu la partie
constitutionnelle de cette audition en
ayant évidemment soin de prendre
connaissance des réponses écrites que
vous pourriez apporter mais laisse la
parole maintenant à Micheline merci
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur le monsieur le
Président
je vais commencer par les dispositions
de l'article 73 de la Constitution que
vous souhaiteriez modifier ou ajouter au
regard de tout ce que vous nous avez
évoqué
précédemment lesquels sont selon vous un
point de blocage pour les évolutions que
vous souhaiteriez
et en 2019 le 26e congrès c'était
prononcé en faveur d'une révision de la
Constitution et d'une loi organique
propre à la Guadeloupe si une loi
organique devait être élaborée pour la
Guadeloupe quel disposition
souhaiteriez-vous y inscrire
quand même plutôt question bon vous le
fera parvenu dans les laits vous savez
je vais peut-être rapide et un peu long
le fondement même de la démocratie et au
cœur du processus de décentralisation
opérer depuis des années
on enlèverait pas avoir
institutionnaliser le principe de
co-construction qui est pour moi la base
même de la relation collective
c'est à quoi nous aspirons une
concentration véritable
je crois se produira à travers le
changement de mentalité
et là pour moi une demande explicite
dans l'appel pour le fond il faut faire
avec nous
la démocratie participative il y a
quelques années la loi disait faire
ensemble pour nous
le nouveau crâne que j'appelle de mes
vœux pour que nous puissions
législatives avec des possibilités
d'adaptation
on constate le principe d'une égalité de
droit entre l'outre-mer et l'Hexagone
toute évolution
permettait de donner un contenu réel
concret à cette égalité de droit pour en
faire une égalité de fait et bienvenue
si on n'est pas encore en présence d'un
pouvoir normatif autonome
il le fait guerre de doute que le
nouveau terme de l'adaptation oppose
signification majeure le régime des
drones et assimilé pas uniforme
chacune de ces collectivités
à vocation particularité
l'évolution sémantique de l'article 73
accentuées en réponse aux aspirations
manifestées dans certaines collectivités
nous plaidons pour une plus grande
association des collectivités
et c'est possible
alors j'aimerais qu'il y a eu au congrès
à une évolution exceptionnelle pour
certaines relativité
notamment la Martinique la Guyane
de sa partenaire
c'est notre audition qui est aujourd'hui
que c'est plus dans un premier temps
celui qui consiste à rationaliser
moderniser optimiser l'action publique
locale afin de renforcer l'efficacité
des services rendus aux citoyens aux
usagers donc à notre population ils
viennent là nécessairement un second
temps
indispensable contre l'occasion de cette
population sachez bien que quel que soit
les décisions quelle que soit notre
position nous le ferons rien sans la vie
de notre population
par elle moi personnellement élu je fais
partie de cette population je suis
peut-être élu et d'autres ont aussi
décidé qu'ils peuvent nous permettre
d'avancer sans que cela entrave par la
suite
l'évolution de notre région
voilà un peu quelques mois je veux pas
rentrer vraiment dans un débat
la coopération régionale auquel vous
êtes très attaché puisque j'ai eu le
loisir le participe à votre intégration
au sein de l'Océ pour la Guadeloupe ce
cadre actuel justement est-il
satisfaisant ou souhaiteriez-vous plus
de liberté comme le permet l'article 74
de la Constitution et quel serait votre
avis sur un éventuelle fusion ou
réécriture des articles 73 et 74 ouvrant
la voie à des statues sur mesure et à
l'effacement de la distinction d'hommes
comme
cette opération
notre association
c'est une bonne chose
actuelle permet effectivement de tisser
des liens avec nos voisins
aujourd'hui je le dis
nous travaillons
ou encore nous sommes chefs de fil du
projet
nous avons même aujourd'hui j'en parlais
le cyclotron quoi actuellement des
habitants de des îles de la Caraïbe
viennent aujourd'hui se faire soigner en
Guadeloupe donc cette collaboration
cette association se déroule très bien
vous avez besoin d'investir encore plus
d'autres champs de coopération notamment
de l'enseignement supérieur avec un
projet de médecine vallée la faculté de
médecine de plein exercice que j'ai
souhaité de mes vœux qui avancent ce
cabinet dans les études avant très bien
ils nous offre de belles opportunités et
nous avons bientôt développer un qui
partiront en formation je crois que ça
sert plus ici au niveau de France
d'une structure française qui se trouve
à cette Russie ma réponse concernant
réécriture ou plusieurs
urgence pour nous c'est le rationaliser
moderniser d'optimiser l'action publique
locale afin de renforcer l'efficacité
des services rendus aux citoyens ce qui
est important qu'on le veuille ou non
aujourd'hui et je crois que notre
quelque soit l'avion la population
absente qu'on puisse mettre en place de
bonnes politiques publiques pour qu'elle
puisse vivre sereinement dans sa ville
dans sa région
aujourd'hui je sais qu'on a lancé
une forme de décentralisation
ou on a fusionné beaucoup de régions en
mettant 13 régions aujourd'hui au moment
où on regarde le musée de certaines
régions européennes qui sont de plus de
180 milliards et au niveau national
c'est 28 milliards je pense qu'il nous
faut plus de moyens pour que nous
puissions aujourd'hui
mettre en place de bonnes politiques
publiques
pour le texte pour de normes aujourd'hui
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faudrait
laisser en région en fonction de leur
spécificité
faire des propositions et quitte on
puisse les adapter ou les mettre en
place un certain temps et voir par la
suite si ça marche ou pas et prendre les
décisions finales
je t'ai admirer par la proposition de
rédaction et maintenant les travaux que
Michel Magra avait mené avec la
délégation sur la différenciation
territoriale quel cadre pour le sur
mesure pensez-vous que cette rédaction
conviendrait à la Guadeloupe
je dirais que on doit combattre
une évolution sexuelle ça c'est clair
en gros toute famille moi je prends un
exemple simple je le dis souvent toute
famille
quand vous êtes dans une entreprise vous
souhaitez aussi évoluer donc
effectivement la population n'est pas
compte une évolution ou institutionnelle
sanitaire elle attend surtout des élus
l'amélioration continue de la qualité de
service nous sommes aujourd'hui c'est
notre principal responsabilité
cette manière que nous pouvons restaurer
de rien de confiance
de ces dernières années et que nous
devons nous interroger sur l'échec des
politiques publiques et aborder les
défis qui sont présentes à nous avec
un économiste célèbre affirme qu'une
société ne peut avancer parce qu'il y a
des inégalités donc
les probablement adaptés
la plus riche de la France
à nouveau la Guadeloupe se trouve dans
le temps de l'efficacité de l'efficience
des politiques publiques
le temps de croisière leur avenir
en proposant si nous voulons que les
choses avancent il faut que nous
mettions en place de bonnes politiques
et quand cette personne voit que les
choses avancées
pour avancer il fera confiance à ses
politiques
vous remercier juste par le Collectif
pour un projet de guadeloupéen de
société qui est un groupe de jeunes qui
s'intéresse beaucoup à tout ce qui se
passe et notamment cette qui veulent en
savoir un peu plus sur cette évolution
ces projets d'évolution institutionnelle
nous recevons beaucoup de mails enfin
tous les parlementaires et j'aurais aimé
savoir qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cette de cette dynamique mise
en place par des par des jeunes
Guadeloupéens
je pense que l'avenir appartient à la
jeunesse effectivement il faut les
associer et je suis bien placé pour vous
dire que s'il y a un élu qui est le plus
plus le 22 accompagne les jeunes c'est
bien à jalouse qui est aujourd'hui
président de région mais avant était
l'air de la ville de baieau il faut
effectivement compter sur ce jeûne nous
avions un hôtel à Paris où nous avons
bien la disposition de ces jeunes qui
font un travail considérable pour nous
faire des propositions et ensemble que
nous allons évoluer chaque idée chaque
tête chaque politique quel que soit le
mot politique de la personne ce qui est
important pour nous c'est de pouvoir
évoluer mais comme je le dis aujourd'hui
nos concitoyens doivent bénéficier de
politique publique adaptés en réalité
ils vivent sur leur territoire et si
vous avez des gens qui existent des
réponses claires et rapides et c'est à
nous de leur apporter aujourd'hui
je vous remercie infiniment pour ces
propos très éclairages je vais rendre la
parole à notre président pour conclure
merci chers merci monsieur le Président
charlius pour ces éclairages forts
intéressants qui ne font conforter la
nécessité effectivement de requestionner
nous organisations territoriales et
également les rapports avec le
gouvernement le gouvernement
le gouvernement a par ailleurs initié un
certain nombre de travaux sur chacun des
territoires nous verrons nous suivrons
avec beaucoup d'intérêt évidemment les
travaux des différents congrès les
propositions des différentes
collectivités les différents travaux de
l'État pour nourrir cette réflexion que
nous menons au Sénat et permettre de
faire remonter des propositions au
groupe décentralisation installées sous
l'égide du président Larcher en tout cas
merci beaucoup de votre disponibilité et
puis la sincérité de vos propos
juste de mot conclusion c'est possible
bien sûr alors je voulais vous dire
que votre rapport
à la suite parce que souvent nous avons
des missions nous avons des questions et
par la suite ça prend du temps les gars
si vous positif c'est important je pense
c'est la France effectivement a mis
l'organisation différente notamment
Paris Lyon Marseille
il y a aussi des règles de droits pour
les collectivités territoriales je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on devrait effectivement
beaucoup s'appuyer sur les élus en
fonction de leur territoire de leur
collectivités nous saluons l'état
d'esprit renouvelé du pouvoir exécutif
le gouvernement et législatives le Sénat
même si le constituant ne renonce pas
possible de prendre la République
introduit il faut bien l'admettre
davantage de souplesse dans la manière
d'envisager l'administration
territoriales des départements de
commerce nous partageons pleinement ce
changement de méthode
dans la rigueur la plus absolue à
établir les rapports plus fluides avec
l'État priorité
consiste à moderniser
rationaliser pour enfin optimiser
l'exercice de compétences transférées
d'assurer une meilleure qualité et de
services publics
réussir une coopération locale
renouvelée compatible avec les
singularités de l'archipeloupéen un
modèle respectueux de la libre
administration de faire collectivité et
porteurs de développement cohérent
durable et qui ne constitue pas un
échelon institutionnel supplémentaire
avec votre soutien
nouveau contrat écologique et social les
usagers à la coproduction des politiques
publiques et le fil d'Ariane que nous
voulons tisser pour parvenir à regagner
la confiance de la population et renouer
le fil du dialogue nous sommes une
science pour la France on le répète
souvent
nos régions doivent être davantage
sollicité et associés aux grandes
transitions écologique énergétiques nous
sommes pauvroyeurs d'avis pour la
communauté nationale sur de nombreux
sujets énergies renouvelable
biodiversité croissance bleu nous vous
sollicitons vivement afin que notre
expertise dans un sujet soit davantage
reconnu la Guadeloupe
avant adoption de l'élaboration de la
loi et du Règlement appliquons la loi de
82 vraiment beaucoup de choses avancent
merci à vous
merci monsieur le Président et soyez une
nouvelle fois rassurée sur le fait que
cette maison le Sénat est avant tout
votre chambre la chambre des
collectivités et que nous sommes votre
porte-voix et celle de votre population
et que nous sommes désireux bien
évidemment de tenir compte de vos
recommandations de vos préconisations de
vos souhaits d'évolution et nous en
seront évidemment le garant auprès de
vous et de votre population si cette
réforme venait à aboutir dans les
conditions qui sont pour l'instant pas
encore tout à fait des figues en tout
cas merci beaucoup de vos propos et je
vous souhaite une bonne fin de journée à
vous merci président merci à vous merci
à tous équipe nous reste quelques mois
j'espère que les choses avanceront
rapidement avant
peut-être que j'y serai on ne sait pas
le Sénat ouvre le champ des possibles
président bonne fin de journée